hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry and
tonight we're gonna watch the trailer
the second trailer dose were the rocks
Hercules you know who else is Hercules
this is it's a Brett Ratner moving oh
yeah yeah it's a Brett Ratner movie
there is best director of all time after
not directing the Oscars after directing
X been the last stand
I mean I know he's done a couple of
things there Tower Heist which was
actually pretty funny he's still got
everyone concerned that the x-men
franchise was done here we are form of
easily the yeah so we're gonna watch
this trailer I like the first trailer
I'm a little bit cheesy at the end with
a rock going other than that it looks
pretty cool though have you seen the
first trailer no so there's gonna be
brand new for Jerry yes a little bit
familiar for me it's gonna be an
interesting dynamic tonight Oh totally
suck if there's one of those trailers
where there's nothing different about it
except for like three shots
I hate those yeah I hate those I hate
those trailers oh good it's been
approved for all Jews surprisingly Jews
gonna watch this movie really loved
their Greek approve for appropriate
audiences yeah not you immature [ __ ]
out there see look how cool that looks
up front the base wide like a 300 whoa
yeah interesting music
yeah drop your boner sounds really
cheesy the same shot again no no I hate
snakes they're using a queasiness
tonnage remix I know here the image
Shane's voiceover nah
haha sorry
damn the rock actually pretty cool
that's where you're lying
this movie looks pretty sweet did
hail Hydra hi max hi max do I really
want to watch that movie actually I was
pretty hooked you know it's got like a
really cheesy yeah it's like cheesy but
it looks like it'll be like a total fun
movie at the same time maybe I don't
know what to think about this because
like half of it looks like wow that's
really badass and intense looking and
the other half looks like a really
cheesy candy coated 300 yeah I will give
you that but still what looks good to me
looks worth watching that's I guess
that's why I mean like the action scenes
look like they're gonna be worth
watching I like a good actually it'll
certainly be worth you know popcorn and
a soda for sure oh yeah I know that's
what I mean like can you imagine that
popcorn soda you're in the theater
Arclight reserve seating you gotta kick
that [ __ ] out of your seat did
you see Hercules I would toys here these
are just because it's like it's a movie
not a film you've been argillite lately
they're dicks that [ __ ] go there now
they're dicks everywhere yeah well
that's full of like dicks now Arclight
you guys take recommendations from your
audience dude you got to get that [ __ ]
up Patrol young people I see on their
[ __ ] phones they're usually right
next to me [ __ ] the cool stuff looks
really cool I don't know I mean granted
it's just a trailer it makes this movie
look really totally uneven duh it looks
like [ __ ] well that's the big reason why
I watch it doesn't look intentionally
bad it looks like they [ __ ] up a few
times and I like watching the movie that
it's [ __ ] up that trailer went from
like oh okay oh oh how many times are we
gonna pull the whole like walking out of
a bathtub and taking off your robe trick
that's always sexy I know but they did
it in it looked like it appeared two or
three separate scenes in this same shape
I heard that's the Rock's real facial
hair but it looks fake yeah something
about that much facial around the rock I
just don't think I'm happy Brett
Ratner's you know branching out like I
hate to see somebody pigeon-holed run
like this yeah it used to be good rush
hour one
rush hour two they needed excellent last
day of rush hour 3 anyway guys thanks
for recommending that trailer yeah
nothing like Duany
Johnson over here so if you're new the
channel summary or salvation and
Christian Bale hopper Christian Bale
suck balls
he was really committed he was really
committed to sucking balls never shut
outs here we go that boy 9 8 7 6 1 he's
said meet your new subscribers than
watching your reaction videos and holy
crap you have me busting out laughing
your trailer reactions rule I know it's
a little early but shout out please Lou
question work it's never too early never
too early to ask for a shadow never
people who don't subscribe ask for
shoutouts
some people don't subscriber they just
keep checking our videos all the time
and there are some people who subscribe
I saw this one dick who went on like so
many of my videos just to talk [ __ ]
about me it's like it's one thing to
watch one video and be like stop this
you suck yeah there's any go on a bunch
and be like no I'm gonna start rally
against initiative yeah anyway back to
you bad boy 9 8 7 6 1 happy to have you
as a new subscriber as a personal token
you know every new subscriber gets to
have a dick suck right now there's a
woman knocking at your door my friend go
get your dick sucked because you're a
bad boy Alex Maroof oh he said in the as
above so below trailer video he said
shout out man in the big hero 6 1
he said shout out man well in the first
one it seems like he thinks you might be
somebody called shout out man
yeah and in the second one maybe he's
asking if you want to shout out man yeah
shout out man the greatest shout out her
in the world war you he doesn't this is
an established character she's familiar
this is the villain from the shout out
Alex mark ruffalo yeah
Giselle Blake now I checked out Giselle
Blake's profile cuz I'm like this girl's
pretty cute and then I found out that
Giselle Blake is actually a man who
transformed into a lady and you were
[ __ ] hot dude really huh hope it's
okay that I shared your personal
information out there but it was on your
YouTube account so I figured on that
person she I'll call you she he said
you're hilarious Ryan I'm glad to be a
real reject to which I said thanks tits
happy to have you be a real reject you
got a great-looking [ __ ] and you're
cute keep that [ __ ] up then she said I
can't believe you're a but my comment
Thank You Ryan that is sweet honestly
you're not bad yourself sir could I so
kindly get a shout-out please and I said
you got it man just make sure you suck
my dick once I give you a shout-out some
of this is it has been embellished for I
don't know what effect you know I'm
telling us story here so I wanna up the
amount of times you said [ __ ] in this
video in reality the true story I didn't
actually say most of what I said I
figure you know as a storyteller I
should I yeah I should take liberty and
give me the pretty good give me death
Giselle dude we got of me you'll be the
first guy I have sex with let's do this
does it count
yeah I'm sure it was a count as a guy no
tell me if it counts yourself